[Music]
um hi everyone my name is Eleanor
um like they said in the introduction I
am a full stack software engineer and
today I'm going to be talking to you
about how to fail successfully
so by that I mean how to overcome your
fear of failure as a software
engineering intern
so a little more background about me
um like they said I'm a full stack
engineer the company I work at is called
fellow.app it's based in Ottawa Canada
and I've only been full-time there for
about the last nine months I started in
January
before that I was an intern for a while
and so the experience of being an intern
is still very fresh with me it's still
less than a year since then and before I
was an internet fellow I interned at
three other software companies during my
software engineering degree and so I've
had many News starts with different
companies and different code bases and
it's been my experience that being a new
employee at a new company with all this
new information coming in is a common
situation for imposter syndrome to set
in
there aren't many things in Tech that I
think I'm an expert in yet but I think
that I have enough first-hand experience
with imposter syndrome to talk about it
with you today my experience with
imposter syndrome even included
preparing for this talk so I'm very well
versed in what it feels like
so let's define our terms what is
imposter syndrome the basis of imposter
syndrome is the fear of being found out
it's this idea that somehow you have
convinced everyone around you you are a
lot more qualified than you actually are
and the only way that you can really
combat this at least in my experience is
just getting used to your skill set
getting comfortable in it and learning
more so that you can get used to like
what you actually know
and unfortunately in that process you're
going to have to get used to asking for
help you're going to make a lot of
mistakes and you're going to have to get
used to saying I don't know however if
you're experiencing imposter syndrome
all of these things are going to feel
like personal failures which is why I
call overcoming them failing
successfully
so let's take a step back and talk a
little bit about what it's like being an
intern and the reason I want to do this
is that although I want to Target this
talk to people who are current interns
and people who are looking to be
interned soon it's also important I
think to address this to managers and
people who are co-workers of current
interns because they're still very
relevant
however if you're a manager or a team
lead or a senior engineer it's likely
that you haven't been an intern for
quite some time so I want to take a sec
just to remind you what that's like
so this is my personal experience of
course
um in my degree I worked really hard I
didn't love being a student but I still
did all the work all the assignments as
best as I could to get good grades and I
studied really hard for interviews that
meant doing all the leap code problems
or whatever else you have to do to study
for those and so by doing all this
studying and background
stuff I felt like I actually knew a lot
of theory I felt like I was well versed
in software engineering and I could
accomplish a lot
so I had confidence going into the jobs
however if the job have show up on the
first day and the job uses technologies
that I'm unfamiliar with then you start
to sort of doubt yourself you start to
wonder maybe I actually know nothing
because when you are starting out a new
job you are limited to the technologies
that your employer uses and that might
mean you can't show them everything that
you're capable of for instance at fellow
this was after five years of engineering
school
but I wasn't very good at react I hadn't
used react very much so all of my
engineering knowledge all of this random
Theory and algorithms and stuff that I
could talk about it was all narrowed
down into whether or not I could
actually build a good react component
and I really couldn't I didn't know a
lot of react so that's when I started to
doubt myself and that's when imposter
syndrome starts to set in
something I think is important when you
are hiring interns is making sure that
you're assigning the meaningful projects
there is this management Theory I think
it's called management Theory X and Y
and there's a whole bunch to it I won't
go into it because I'm not a business
student
but essentially it boils down to the
fact that people will work the way they
are expected to so if you micromanage
people and you treat them as though they
are going to mess up and you don't give
them much responsibility because you
don't want them to cause any problems
then that is the level at which they're
going to work at they're probably not
going to be very interested in doing
good work because they're going to feel
like you expect them to fail but if you
give them a lot more room to grow and
you show them their opinions and their
ideas are valuable
then it will let them perform at a
higher level and I think this is very
relevant to the idea of the intern
project this is something that I've
experienced quite a lot when I say the
intern project I mean like a small side
project or menial tasks that are
assigned to interns so they don't mess
with the larger code base or they don't
delete customer data they don't cause
bugs on production
however if you are an intern working on
the intern project
you can sort of tell that the tasks that
you're doing are meaningless and it will
really enforce any kind of imposter
syndrome that you're already
experiencing
furthermore if you are just working
alone on this project which was my
experience a few times it means that
you're isolated and you can't learn from
other people around you you can't learn
from your teammates you can't learn from
their reviews and other things which is
something that's really important as an
intern one of the most valuable things
you can get from an internship is other
people's input and advice because that's
what you'll learn
I actually worked at a company one time
where I was my entire scrum team because
I was entirely on my own intern project
and so if I'd been following their scrum
practices exactly I was my own scrum
master and I would have had to sit down
by myself every morning and have a stand
up to talk about my project
but obviously that's ridiculous and I
didn't do it but that was really the
structure that I was working along and I
didn't I didn't learn anything in that
internship because I was just
regurgitating my existing knowledge and
I didn't have any reason to build on
that
so as managers it is important to assign
interns low urgency High importance
projects this is a term that my manager
uses and she's great with interns
um and when I say low urgency I mean if
it goes over time or if it goes over
budget it's not a big deal it's okay
it's not a very high stress environment
if the intern makes a mistake that's all
right you can take the time to fix it
it's not very serious however the work
that they're producing is important
enough that they can see it reflected in
the end product they can see
how it impacts the end users how it is
valuable to the company and that's
really really important when you're an
intern because it will motivate you to
do better work and it will help you
decrease any existing imposter syndrome
so now that I've talked about being an
intern a little bit you're probably
wondering that's all great but how can I
fail successfully how can I overcome my
fear of failure and fail successfully
so first point ask for help I know that
is pretty straightforward but it is it
sort of boils down to the belief that it
is okay to not know everything it's okay
to admit that you need help sometimes as
an intern you aren't going to know
everything
the the way that I think about asking
for help is that the sooner that you
realize that you are stuck in a position
you're up against a wall you have tried
everything but you just can't make
something work the sooner you realize
that you're in that position the sooner
you can ask for help and overcome that
and just continue working because if you
do that very quickly it's less time
stuck in that position of feeling like
you don't know anything and you're
worried to ask for help and the longer
you sustain that the more imposter
syndrome is going to fit in so if you
can realize you're stuck ask for help
carry on it's like nothing happened
I actually have a story my first time my
first week at fellow I was assigned some
very basic tickets at least I assumed
they were basic and I got stuck because
I wasn't very familiar with react so I
was having trouble navigating the code
base
and also I couldn't figure out the
framework we were using it's called Pros
mirror if anyone's familiar with it it's
for document collaboration
and I started to really doubt myself in
this position because again five years
engineering experience you know I
couldn't complete these really basic
tasks
but I was comparing myself as well to
the other intern who I knew was really
good at react so that didn't help
anything and we were working on the same
tickets and I knew that he was probably
just killing them just doing great and I
was not able to do anything at all and
So eventually I realized I wasn't going
to be able to make any progress on these
and I realized that the best person to
ask for help was actually going to be
the other intern and this was really
hard for me because I didn't want to
admit admit that I needed help from the
other person that was supposed to be at
the same level as I was but I had to
swallow my pride and realize that I
needed help so I asked him I messaged
him very cautiously on slack and I said
hey I'm stuck and luckily he said yeah
thank God I'm also really confused this
code makes no sense and I was so
relieved and we were able to work
together and complete the tickets it all
turned out great
but it really helped my imposter
syndrome to know that I wasn't the only
one feeling confused and I never would
have come to that realization if I
hadn't reached out and asked for help
and also it was really helpful to know
that I was actually capable of
completing the work that I was assigned
even though it meant having to
collaborate with someone else I was
still capable I could still do things in
that position
so as an intern what are some things
that we can do to make it less scary to
ask for help because it is an
intimidating thing to do
something that's really helped me
whenever I ask for help is presenting
questions in the context of what I
already do know so by that I mean if
you're saying hey I'm stuck this is the
error message I got can you fix it that
feels like you're admitting that you
can't do anything but instead if you say
hey I was writing this function I got
stuck at this line because I wasn't sure
about this whatever other function I'm
calling
I've tried x y and Zed I've read this
documentation I'm just stuck about this
little part can you explain that to me
that first of all is going to make it a
lot easier for the other person to
answer your question but also it's going
to make it feel less as though you're
admitting that you don't know things
because you are telling them all of the
things that you do know you're just
missing one puzzle piece that maybe they
can provide you with
secondly like I've said before always
remember that no one in software knows
everything when you're new to the
industry it might feel like you're
surrounded by people who know so much
stuff but realistically it is a massive
world and it's impossible for everyone
in software to know everything about
everything
so as a team what can you do to help
interns feel less intimidated asking for
help
I think this is underrated but
encouraging collaborations socializing
within a team is really helpful because
instead of asking people who are
complete strangers for help you can ask
someone that you might think is your
friend or you have some degree of
personal connection with and that makes
it a lot easier because at least you
have a basis with that person to work
off of as opposed to just approaching
someone out of the blue
and finally when you are answering
questions if possible I think it's
really helpful to provide guidance as
opposed to just a solution so you don't
even necessarily have to give a straight
answer you can say hey have you checked
out these docs have you read this
article have you looked in this file at
this function have you seen what this
other person wrote about it because that
way the intern will actually or
whoever's asking the question will
actually learn something from that
answer as opposed to just getting a
block of code back because you just send
them a block of code you're probably
going to get that same question a week
later because they haven't learned
anything from it but if you can provide
them guidance it will be really helpful
for both of you
secondly uh you can really help
imposter syndrome is very scary because
the idea of making mistakes is one of
the worst things that could possibly
happen in that scenario and
unfortunately you are going to make
mistakes it is going to happen and
that's really all there is to it you
just have to get used to the idea that
you are going to make mistakes
um it doesn't mean that you aren't
qualified it doesn't mean that you're
doing something wrong it's just
something that happens sometimes so what
can we do to come to terms with this
idea
well uh just make the most of it I know
that's a cliche I know that's uh you
know it might seem obvious but it is
sometimes difficult and I have a story
that I think about every day pretty much
of a silly mistake I made a long time
ago I was at a cafe I was making my
coffee they'd given it to me and I was
trying to figure out where the sugar
Shaker was because I like sugar in my
coffee and so I put what I thought was
sugar in my coffee and the Barista turns
around and says why are you putting salt
in your coffee why would you want that
and instead of acknowledging that I had
made a mistake and that I had done
something wrong I said no actually I
love salt in my coffee I am just gonna
take this thank you though
and I went and I had the nastiest drink
of my whole life just because I was too
proud or embarrassed or awkward to admit
that I had made a very innocent mistake
and I could have just said can I have a
new coffee instead but I didn't I don't
know why but I just couldn't do it in
that moment
and this I want to use as an analogy
here because it's very it would seem to
be very easy to say hey I did something
wrong this was silly I don't know why I
did that but can you help me can we can
we fix this together because it would be
so easy just to make me a new coffee but
in that moment that was the hardest
thing to do in the world
so mistakes will happen in a variety of
scenarios we're all human we all make
mistakes all day long and unfortunately
you spend a lot of your time at work and
so you're going to make a decent
percentage of your mistakes at work
and the best you can really do is try to
make the most of it in this situation
and move on and hope that it doesn't
happen again do everything you can to
learn from it and put it in place so
that you hope it doesn't happen again
there are a few things that I think we
can do as management to make it less
scary and make it less likely that
serious mistakes will happen at work
first I really hope no one is actually
doing this but don't encourage a culture
of blame I think that when a serious
like let's say worst case scenario a
major bug goes to production your first
instinct shouldn't be okay let's point
fingers let's figure out whose fault
this was who can we pin the blame on
your instinct should be instead let's
collectively figure out how we can solve
this issue and that will make it easier
for whoever it was maybe someone was
actually responsible for this bug it
will make it easier for them to figure
help you figure out what went wrong as
opposed to them being too scared to
mention anything because they're worried
of having the blame on them
secondly I've always been really
inspired by managers that I've had
who've admitted to times that they've
made serious mistakes because it helps
me realize that it's very human to do so
and you can rise through the ranks you
can still have a successful career and
have made mistakes in the past
and finally for everyone's peace of mind
there are a lot of software processes
that you can put around your development
life cycle like Ci pipelines or just
stringent review processes so that the
worst mistakes don't actually make it
that far I think this will really help
everyone feel a little more safe with
the idea of making mistakes
so finally my biggest point is saying I
don't know and I know this sounds a
little counter-intuitive but I don't
mean just say I don't know everywhere
all the time but be confident in what
you do know but also be transparent in
what that limit is and what you still
need to learn
so by that I mean know what you know and
what you don't know and like I said this
might be counterintuitive it might feel
like you're admitting as though you're
under qualified or unintelligent but if
you can genuinely sit down with yourself
and figure out what you do know about a
topic if you can Define this boundary of
this is what I do know and figure out
your the limits of your knowledge once
you establish that you can be very
transparent with people when you're
talking with them about what you don't
know and it will feel less like an
admittance of some personal failure
because you've established look this is
all the stuff that I do know that just
happens to be outside of this range
plus it will help with imposter syndrome
because imposter syndrome is telling you
that everyone believes you know a lot
more than you do but if you can be
honest and say hey this is what I do
know this is what I don't know it's
really impossible for imposter syndrome
to tell you that you are making
something up or that people are
convinced you're more qualified than you
are
this is really helpful when responding
to questions feedback and criticism this
was a situation that used to give me a
lot of anxiety because first I was
worried that people would ask me
questions I didn't know the answer to or
that they would point out things that I
did wrong while I was presenting to
everybody
but if you can remember why you think
you're right why you made the decisions
when you're coding and also be
transparent about what you have left to
learn it makes it really decreases your
anxiety in that environment and it makes
you feel less defensive when people ask
you questions or suggest that maybe you
could have done something differently
when people do maybe they ask you a
question say hey why did you use this
approach instead of that one you can
discuss your thought process instead of
being like oh they they think I'm doing
it wrong they think I made a mistake you
can say hey this is why I did it this
way I appreciate your input maybe we can
figure out a better solution together
you can be curious about their input and
you can collaborate on a new solution
something that's helped me as an intern
in these situations where people are
asking me questions is just practicing
being again very transparent and saying
very simple things like can't you
clarify what you mean maybe they asked a
really confusing question you need more
context or that's a really good point I
hadn't thought about it like that or
just I don't know is a valid answer it
is quite possible someone asks you a
question and you don't know the answer
to it and that's all right in that
moment you shouldn't make up an answer
that sounds right which is something
that I used to try to do it doesn't that
doesn't benefit anybody the most
efficient thing to do in that moment is
just to say I don't know I can find out
later I will let you know but right now
I don't know and that's honestly that's
okay
and on the topic of remembering why you
think you're right don't assume that
other people are always right even if
you feel like you aren't very qualified
there are there are a lot of ways that
other people might seem right that
aren't actually the case
one of them is just confusing code that
you might come across so uh something
that happened to me recently was at work
we had this code that was supposed to
Cache values that were returned from an
API to avoid excess API calls and I knew
that we did this I knew why we did it
and I was building a new feature
on some of the old code and I couldn't
figure out why we weren't caching the
values there and I assumed that I
misunderstood it and that we should have
been caching or that yeah we shouldn't
have been caching but I was I was doing
something wrong and so I was stuck with
this for a while and eventually I had to
go ask the developer who built the code
I said hey why aren't we doing that here
and he said oh yeah you're totally right
we should be cashing there we just
missed it in that spot and I felt so
silly because I could have just added
that code I could have just realized we
should have been doing this here the
code is wrong I can add that feature but
instead I was convinced that I was I was
doing something wrong in that moment
secondly I think it's a stereotype
that's absolutely true is that Engineers
really love to have strong opinions
and that's okay but when someone comes
to you with a really strong opinion and
you're experiencing imposter syndrome it
might be easy to feel as though they're
telling you that you're wrong so
sometimes it's good to step back and
consider is the reproach actually better
what they're suggesting or are they just
trying to say it louder so they have
something to say
and finally take their take their
opinion into account that's totally fine
they might be giving you valuable
feedback but also if you can remember
everything that you do know you can add
it onto that instead of just overriding
it with someone else's opinion
and finally I think that it's important
to note that everything in my
presentation so far is going to be a lot
stronger with people who are part of
underrepresented groups in software
engineering so for instance me as a
woman in software engineering I have a
lot of fear of confirming stereotypes
that people might have about women in
engineering
and the only way that I really found
to counteract that is by having diverse
representation in management right now I
have a female manager her name is
Alexandra sunderlin she just wrote a
book it's called remote Engineering
Management she's great if you want to
check her out but having that diverse
representation in management really made
me feel as though I had someone that I
could look up to who I saw myself in and
I could see them being assertive and
making decisions and being respected in
the company it made it feel like it was
okay for me to be part of this
underrepresented group as well in
software engineering
so you're wondering maybe whether I
follow my own advice I do as much as
really anyone can I think for instance
I'm always seeking opportunities to feel
more confident in my skills by exiting
my comfort zone for instance flying from
Canada to Korea today to talk to you
about all this this is hugely out of my
comfort zone but here I am anyway
uh something that's really helpful for
me is being transparent about what I do
and what I don't know when I'm
responding to questions that has helped
me immensely in combating imposter
syndrome is just being very
straightforward about the things that
I'm confident in and the things that I
have left to learn and finally always
asking for help and clarification when I
realized that I need it and again that
might seem obvious but it's much easier
to do that than just be stuck in that
position feeling too embarrassed by the
fact that you don't know something
so finally if you have any takeaways
here please remember to ask for help
make mistakes and say I don't know
thank you very much
[Applause]